so Cavanaugh did Brett Kavanaugh did an
interview on Fox News last night and
look obviously as you know by now I I
think that he's innocent I think he's
being smeared by a bunch of disgraceful
opportunists in the Democrat Party that
said he didn't come across well in his
interview in my opinion it was not it
was not a great performance and I really
hope that he changes his approach for
Thursday okay it's it's very important
so and I know I was talking about this
on Facebook last night and most people
were saying oh I thought he did really
well so wonderful he did a wonderful job
and maybe some of them really do think
you did a wonderful job but I think a
lot of those people a lot of the
conservatives are saying that was a
great interview I think a lot of them
are they're just saying that because
they support Cavanaugh and they feel bad
for him for good reason you know but so
for that reason they don't want to be
critical but we do need to be critical
here because it's really important that
he changes his approach for the hearing
on Thursday
now I understand look to be to be on
live TV is disorienting especially if
you're not used to it to be on live TV
under these circumstances is is I can't
even imagine how overwhelming that is so
you're gonna be nervous and and I also
know that of course he's got PR people
around him he's got his team around him
and they're they're coaching him they're
there helping him they're you know
they're they're giving him advice
doesn't mean that he's guilty the fact
that you've got people helping you that
just means that you're in a very
high-pressure high-stakes situation and
you're not used to being in this kind of
situation you're not used to being on TV
you're not used to this kind of scrutiny
and so you got people advising you you
know like anybody would but I think the
advice that he's getting is just is just
it's not good advice it's in my opinion
you know for one thing he sounded very
scripted and he was repeating the same
lines over and over and over again and I
was watching with my wife and we were
both just cringing like by the fifth
time that he repeated himself the exact
same line verbatim like he was literally
read like there was a teleprompter it
was it was we were cringing yeah I think
the worst thing now is to sound scripted
that's the
worse thing it is it is much I mean if
you're worried about well if you don't
you know if you don't stick to a script
and you might go you you might get angry
and go off the rails a little bit and
get away and run it you know run away
with your words well I think it's much
better to err on that side of the
spectrum than on the side of the
spectrum of sounding of sounding
scripted for another thing you know he
tried I think he tried to run too far in
the other direction
by saying that's because he was trying
to combat the the image of this image
that's being painted of him as being
this kind of high school and college
frat bro kind of guy who's going around
getting drunk all the time and just
being a jerk and obnoxious so he's
trying to come he's trying to dispel
that notion and so he said in the
interview that well the main thing he
was worried about in high school was
doing his service projects he said that
multiple times about his service
projects and going to church and getting
good grades that was the only thing he's
worried about and maybe that's true I
mean it's possible that he really was
that straight-laced in high school but
the vast majority of high school kids
aren't like that
the massive vast majority of high school
kids even if they do service projects
that's not their main concern in life is
oh I just want to do my service projects
okay I certainly wasn't like that in
high school I was maybe I wasn't even
close to that and you don't need it you
don't need to be that way and he doesn't
need to portray himself that way I think
it's okay to be a little bit more real
and say you know look I was I was a kid
but making that admission yeah look I
was a kid I mean I did dumb things to
make that admission that's not the same
thing as admitting that oh I I tried to
commit sexual assault right and then the
last thing is Cavan on this this was the
main thing to me Cavanaugh you he was
trying to be very restrained like I said
that was obviously the advice that he'd
been given and so he was trying to hold
back his anger he refused to criticize
Democrats he refused to criticize the
media was given multiple opportunities
he was asked he was asked where do you
think this is coming from why do you
think they're coming after you do you
think it's politically motivated
and he was asked you know the New Yorker
ran this this article about you there
are no witnesses there knows no
corroboration do you think it was the
right decision for them to run the
article and in both cases he went back
to the script and said I'm not gonna
comment I'm not gonna comment on motives
and I know that that's look I know that
in DC for whatever reason the PR people
that's how they advise that's how they
advise politicians to behave that's
that's the response oh I'm not gonna
comment on that I just think it's bad
advice I think you need to be a human
being and react like any other human
being would you're angry you're ticked
off you're indignant and obviously you
know that yes it's this is irresponsible
reckless journal journalism the
Democrats are obviously politically
motivated we all know that he knows it
it obviously makes him very angry so
just say it why not say it what are you
worried about at this point you're
worried that if you say it that the
Democrats what won't like you I mean
come on they already hate your guts
they're trying to destroy your life
there's nothing you can say that's gonna
make them more aggressive towards you
they're already as aggressive as they
could possibly be so just to let it rip
is what I would say that's what Clarence
Thomas did I really hope that judge
Kavanagh before the hearing on Thursday
he should go I mean I'm sure he's seen
it before but maybe go again and watch
that clip of Clarence Thomas that
Clarence Thomas in his hearing when he
was confronting the bogus allegations
against himself and he launched into
this three-minute monologue which was
very aggressive he went on the offensive
he was angry he called these people out
he called it what it was and and I think
Cavanaugh needs to have another moment
like that a raw real angry moment where
he's just acting like any human being
would in this situation where you're
being lied about and your reputation is
being destroyed and your family is being
attacked all right so there
the main thing we want to talk about all
of the when you look at Washington DC
and you see all the incompetence and all
the chaos all of that is primarily
fueled by two things maliciousness and
cowardice and democrats will generally
contribute the maliciousness the malleus
and republicans will contribute the
cowardice and you can really see how all
this works when you look at the
Cavanaugh situation it's all been
illustrated for us let's remember that
this whole and I don't think this can be
emphasized enough
this whole Cavanaugh circus could have
been avoided from the very beginning if
not for GOP cowardice GOP cowardice is
what got this ball rolling because
President Trump was advised by you know
by his people by Republicans to nominate
Brett Kavanaugh rather than Amy Barrett
Amy Barrett who's the extremely
conservative woman and he was advised
though to go with Kavanagh because
Republicans were concerned that
Barrett's social conservatism might
upset the Democrats but of course the
Democrats have no power so it doesn't
matter if you upset them yet Republicans
still decided to go with the more mild
figure in hopes of avoiding any kind of
nasty altercations with the powerless
opposition party which is the kinds of
decision that they're always making
Republicans are always doing they're
always doing kind of like what I do when
I shop for wine okay good because I
don't know a good wine from a bad wine
so I always just buy the second cheapest
wine not the cheapest because I figured
the cheapest is probably bad but not the
most expensive because I don't pay for
that so I just go for the second
cheapest that's always that's just
always what I do and I actually do that
when I'm shopping for most things
because I don't know I don't know what
any you know I just I have no idea what
I'm doing a life I'm clueless
so I always just go I just go one step
up from the cheapest and Republicans do
the same thing all the time
they rarely go and make the worst
decision but they don't make the best
decision either so with the supreme so
with the Supreme Court nominee that
that's kind of what they did there
obviously worst there were worse people
they could have chosen than Brett
Kavanaugh I mean Brett Kavanaugh was a
good choice don't get me wrong but he
wasn't the best choice from up from a
conservative and constitutional
perspective it wasn't the absolute best
home run choice that would have been Amy
Barrett and so they go for this kind of
intermediate route hoping that it will
appease conservatives and liberals at
the same time but what they still don't
understand somehow is that Democrats
will never be appeased ever they will be
vicious no matter what they will treat
every Republican measure every
Republican legislation or appointment as
the end of human civilization no matter
what no matter who it is no matter what
it is no matter the situation they are
permanently stuck on DEFCON one setting
no matter what so if they're gonna panic
regardless you may as well give them
something to panic about remember that's
what you're that's that's the famous
line that that everyone's dad used to
say stop crying I'll give you something
cry it to cry about which I don't think
of my dad I don't know if my dad ever
actually said that but but but that's
what Republicans should say to Democrats
okay so okay you want to cry I'll give
you something to cry about that should
have been there that should have been
their strategy their approach for the
last two years oh you guys are gonna
panic over everything you're gonna freak
out well I'll give you something to
freak out about here you go
but they don't Republicans have the
power to shove whatever they want down
the Democrats throats but they're too
scared to use that power for some reason
they compromise even when there's no
reason to compromise and even though the
other side has no power and so they have
no leverage and even though the other
side really won't accept anything but
complete surrender anyway and that's
what brought us to the Brett Kavanaugh
situation and again don't get me wrong I
think Gavin Kavanagh is a very very
solid choice I thought that all along
and obviously what's happening to him
now is horrific he doesn't deserve any
of it
but but it all you know if they had put
bear if they had put a me bear it up for
the court Democrats they would have
freaked out they would have lost their
minds they would have said oh they're
gonna overheat overturn roe v-- wade but
I doubt they would have been able to
conjure up they couldn't have gone this
route with a woman I mean I guess you
can't you can't assume anything but
nothing is beneath them but most likely
with a woman they would not have tried
to conjure up a sexual assault
allegation so they would have had to
just freak out the whole time about you
know it's gonna be Handmaid's Tale and
all that kind of stuff but they did that
anyway with Brett Kavanaugh you see so
it didn't make a difference
Republican cowardice made all this
possible got the ball rolling and
Republican cowardice has kept it going
sustained it leftist liberals and
Democrats are complaining that the GOP
leadership has been bullying the
Cavanaugh accusers claiming that they've
been they've been bullying Christine
Ford but the truth as usual is the
opposite of that Republicans have spent
the last week groveling at at Ford's
feet making concession after concession
begging her to come to DC and tell her
unsubstantiated uncorroborated story on
national television I mean they've been
begging her they said come here we'll go
there we'll do anything you want
anything please dr. Ford please they've
been begging her and the back-and-forth
was all in bad faith Democrats were
simply stalling as they routed through
Cavanaugh's closet for any other
skeletons real or imagined that they
could find and now an Republicans very
generously gave them the space and the
opportunity to conduct that search
that's what this was all about it was
obvious to anyone with two brain cells
in their head the past week as
Republicans have been negotiating trying
to get her to come and testify it was
clear to everyone that they were just
stalling in order to give themselves
more time to dig up more dirt and for
some unbelievable reason the
stupid Republicans let them do it and
said okay fine yes we'll give you more
time I mean you absolute idiots just
hold the vote what are you doing
Republicans could put an end to this at
any time all they have to do is confirm
Cavett all they could have confirmed him
last week that can confirm them now
there's nothing to be gained by waiting
unless the continued character
assassination of Brett Kavanaugh is
something that they consider to be a
gain which it is a gain for Democrats
and it's a gain not only because it
destroys this particular Supreme Court
nominee but also because it serves as a
warning to any other potential
conservative judges what Democrats are
doing is they're cutting off Cavanaugh's
heads they're putting it on a none upon
us on a spike and they're kind of
putting it on on the edge of the town
and saying abandon all hope ye who enter
here this this is what happens if the
Republicans nominate you this is what
we're gonna do to you and Republicans
are allowing them to do this
I mean Mitch McConnell gave a nice
speech yesterday and and he was very
aggressive and and he called all this
what what it was what it is he said that
this is a smear campaign and on and on
run but if that's how you feel why are
you allowing it to get why don't you
just hold the vote if you know that it's
a smear campaign
why are you humoring it why are you
entertaining it do you know what
Democrats would do in this you know what
Democrats would do we all know what
Democrats would do in this exact same
situation do you know how they would
respond if they controlled Congress and
it was their Supreme Court nominee being
slandered they would flip a middle
finger to the Republicans and to the
conservative voters and they would
confirm their nominee without hesitation
they would be holding a hearing they
would be doing an investigation they
wouldn't be doing anything they would
say oh you don't like it try and stop us
oh you can't stop us
well too bad I mean you guys could cry
about it but we're just going to do what
we're gonna do we don't care if you cry
about it it doesn't matter to us
and and Republicans would cry and they
would stomp their feet and conservative
talk show hosts would be sent into a
into a rage about it and and I would
rant about it right now in my car
screaming like a madman and and
conservatives everywhere would complain
about how unfair it all is and Democrats
would just laugh they would say Hugh
suckers I don't care you think we care
that you're upset they wouldn't care how
we feel because they got their guy on
the Supreme Court and that's the only
thing that would matter to them they
would see all the rest of the hysterics
and the outrage as irrelevant a sideshow
unimportant and you know something they
would be absolutely right it's time for
Republicans to take a page from that
playbook the play is very simple it's
called use the power that you have been
given use it you absolute wimps use the
power we gave it to you for a reason
I mean there's you're on the football
field you got the ball in your hand and
there's no one else on the field the
other team hasn't hasn't field in it all
you got to do is just run to the end
zone that's all you have to do but
Republicans are they're afraid they
might hurt they might hurt the other
side's feelings if they could score
touchdown so instead they just run in
circles and then they take a knee and
they wait for the clock to expire I mean
it's unbelievable the it just makes me
even more ticked off that Republican
politicians are out there saying that
this is a smear campaign it's in bad
faith it's dishonest there this is
slander it's terrible oh my gosh it's
horrible they're saying all that stuff
yet they're allowing it to continue and
they're actually gonna they're gonna do
this stupid hearing even though they
they they themselves have said that it's
all in bad faith
did we get cursed I mean as
conservatives how did we get cursed with
this with this party of nincompoops and
spineless gutless cowards how did we end
up this way I mean this this is well we
headed up with this because these are
the people that we vote for guys I mean
that that's how we end up this way it's
by voting all right and you cut it off
there before I have an aneurysm have a
good day
Godspeed